Hey everyone.  We're going to be taking a look at how we can better align employees with the best interests of the firm.
To do that, we're going to be looking at a centralized and decentralized systems.
Gaming the system and a problem solving framework.
Let's jump into it.
Meet Julia.  She's a regional operations director for a fast growing gym chain.
A few months ago, she rolled out a new incentive plan.
Gym managers could earn sizable bonuses, but only only if they cut operating costs by 10% or more.
@ first it looks like a win.
Costs dropped and the spreadsheets glowed green.
However, what we found was that managers were skipping necessary repairs, cutting AC usage and reducing towels and other necessary gym items.
Soon, what happened?
Members began to complain.
Retention fail and complaints rose.
Two gyms shut down due to equipment failures.
This is a classic case of misaligning incentives between the principal and the agent.
To understand what happened, we need to examine Julia's organizational structure.
She runs a decentralized system in this case where local gym managers control their own budgets, scheduling, staffing and maintenance.
We can also define it more generally as a system where those further down the management hierarchy are are more likely to have information first, so they're more informed than their bosses.
In theory, decentralization leverages local knowledge.
Here, agents closest to the customer often have better, more timely information than those at the top.
But decentralization only works if two conditions are met.
Agents must have accurate and relevant information.
Here, agents are empowered to make decisions decisions.
Therefore, they need accurate and relevant information to make choices that align with the organizational's goals.
And two, their incentives must be aligned with the goals of the principal.
In this case, the firm incentives drive behavior.
And misaligned incentives may have agents seeking out personal gain as opposed to the best interest of the firm.
For example, the gym managers and their actions based on the misaligned incentives given to them.
Here they are looking for ways to cut costs.
But it comes at the cost of destabilizing their gems.
Julia gave Baninger's decision rights but incentivized only cost reduction without having balanced performance measures.
Her structure encouraged behaviors that optimize their local metric while undermining firm wide objectives.
Then we also have the centralized system.
This type of system places authority on a top down approach.
Aligning incentives is still important here as well.
And here are a few ways to do that.
Let's start with linking performance metrics to system wide outcomes.
This is when decisions come from the top.
Employees should be rewarded based on how well firm level goals are achieved.
Not Just local or team specific outcomes.
Next, we can create feedback loops between performance and policy.
Frontline workers often implement those policies, but they don't shape them.
Incentives should encourage employees to share insights from the field so they can improve centralized decisions.
Next, we can reward the how and not just the what.
When execution is the employee's main responsibility.
Focus incentives not just on hitting output targets, but how work is performed, especially in customer facing or safety critical roles.
Lastly, promote shared success.
Use team or organization wide bonuses tied to overall firm profitability, customer satisfaction and safety records.
This helps everyone stay invested in the central plan success even if they didn't create it.
Let's continue to move on with our GEM example.
This leads us to the core problem of gaming incentives.
When rewards here are tied too tightly to one metric, especially when thresholds are involved, employees begin to manipulate behavior to maximize their personal gain.
In Julia's case, cost cutting became the singular goal.
So managers did exactly what the system encouraged.
They delayed repairs, reduced cleaning hours and ignored equipment wear.
And they got the customer response from that.
From an organizational economics perspective, this is a form of moral hazard.
Agents take actions that serve their own interest but impose costs on the firm to reduce that gaming.
We have a few things that we can do.
First, we can replace hard targets with continuous incentives.
Hard targets like hitting $100,000 in sales or you don't get a bonus.
They create sharp cliffs in employee behavior.
People either push too hard just to meet threshold or they give up if they don't.
If they think they'll miss it worse when the target is hit, they often coast since there's no more upside.
So if we use continuous or linear incentives where every unit of improvement yields a reward, this encourages sustained effort and minimizes the temptation to just pull or push activity across reporting periods.
As an example, instead of giving a $5,000 bonus for reaching 100,000 of a sales quota, offer 50% for every unit sold, whether it lands or not.
Next, we can use multi dimensional performance metrics.
Here, employees are rewarded for a single metric like cost reduction or sales volume.
They may hit the number in ways that hurt other areas like quality, customer experience, maybe even ethics.
So what we want to do is incorporate multiple performance indicators that reflect reflect the complexity of real world success.
So when employees are accountable for multiple outcomes, they are less likely to gain one at the expense of the other.
So instead of evaluating a customer rep solely based on call volume, add metrics for resolution, quality, customer satisfaction and complaint follow up make manipulation more costly than compliance.
Here, gaming happens when the expected payoff of manipulating the system is greater than the cost, whether in effort, detection, risk or consequences.
So what we want to do is design systems where manipulation is harder, riskier or less lucrative than doing the right thing.
This might mean audit trails, peer review, or reputational consequences tied to gaming behavior.
For example, if a regional manager defers expenses to inflate their quarterly profit, then what we might want to do is tie part of their bonus to accuracy and not just performance.
Lastly, track both inputs and outcomes to detect surface level wins.
With deeper cost, gaming often looks like a success until we look at some of these deeper metrics involved.
For instance, sales may rise while returns spike or cost fall while customer churn increases.
So what we want to do is measure both what employees do and what results from it.
This provides a fuller picture and exposes some short termism or behavior that undermines long term value.
As an example, if maintenance staff are rewarded for completing work orders, then we might want to track equipment failure and equipment failure rates or repeated service requests.
So this pulls us to the three question framework, powerful diagnostic tool for principal agent theory.
We have our first question.
Who was making the bad decision?
Well, in this case of our gym managers, they had all the formal authority and so they had all the decision rights.
Second question, did they have the right information to make a good decision?
Partially.  They understood their budgets but lacked some system wide visibility.
They couldn't see member satisfaction scores or facility risk indicators.
Were their incentives aligned with the firm's objectives?  No.
Their compensation was linked narrowly to short term cost control, not long term customer retention or brand equity.
So in economic terms, this is a classic principal agent problem.
Agents are optimizing their own utility function and complete contracts in a system where residual risk is borne by the firm.
So how can Julia fix it?
Well, she can adjust the incentive structure to reward multidimensional performance, improve internal reporting to obtain real time feedback, reassign high risk decisions to a centralized coordinator, and then tie bonuses to shared metrics and not isolated targets.
Fixing performance starts with fixing the system.
Bad outcomes don't always mean bad people.
It's just bad design.
Julia looked at the incentives that were in place and realized that they didn't work.
By focusing on the three questions, Julia was able to reconsider how to align employees to the firm's best interest.
Creating the proper incentives allow the gyms to improve retention satisfaction and therefore raising overall profit level.
We can conclude by saying that when people have the right information, the right authority and the right incentives, they don't just perform at a personal level.
They perform in the firm's best interest.
And that's it.
Hope you've enjoyed it.